- So in Palace of Curtains, III,
we did a lot of investigation
on the painting.
The varnish was not
something that Magritte
would have chosen for this work.
We realized that this painting
should not be varnished.
We first very carefully test solubility,
and then I removed the dirt
with an aqueous solution,
and then the varnish
was removed with a solvent.
After the varnish
removal, we started to see
how the painting became
more three-dimensional,
appreciating more the
very delicate shadowing
that he does on each side of the forms.
And in the case of the shape on the right,
he did that in reserve.
He painted everything else and left that
ground exposed to then
draw it and paint it.
We revealed very clearly the ground layer,
which had turned yellow.
He actually had painted
in that, in this shape
with white paint, added
white paint to the ground,
almost re-creating a white cloud.
Looking at the lettering,
you can easily tell
that he used a very fluid paint,
and almost continuously he drew it.
So we realized that
possibly he would have used
not only oil, but added
a different mixture
of paint to make the paint very fluid.
He used probably a
quarter of an inch brush.
It was not a calligraphy brush.
If he would have used a calligraphy brush,
he couldn't have, be so precise
in the thickness of the letters.
The other thing that became more evident
with the cleaning was
that you could clearly see
the pencil marks around the shapes.
He actually drew the shapes
before he painted them.
Well, now that the conservation,
the cleaning of the painting is done,
all the subtleties of the painting,
which were obliterated by the varnish,
they are clear now and you can also
appreciate more the delicate
passages of the painting.